[Music]
google cloud external https load
balancer enables you to run and scale
your services behind a single external
ip address it can balance http
and https traffic across multiple
backend instances across multiple
regions it distributes the http and
https traffic to back-ends hosted on a
variety of google cloud platforms such
as google compute engine google
kubernetes engine cloud storage and so
on as well as external backends on the
internet
the load balancer log entries contain
information that would be useful for
monitoring and troubleshooting your
https requests in this video you will
learn how to use external https load
balancer logs to troubleshoot and
resolve 502 errors encountered with the
load balancer
before we troubleshoot a live 502 error
let's understand some possible causes
for 502 errors with the help of the
status details field that exists in the
https load balancing log entries the
status details field contains
information on why the load balancer
return a particular http status it will
have a value for both successful and
fail requests
for a 502 error this field contains one
of the following values which indicates
the cause for the failure failed to
connect to back end means that the load
balancer was unable to establish a
connection with the backend likely
because the backend is not listening on
the specific port
fail to pick back-end indicates that the
load balancer was unable to pick a
back-end because all back-ends are
unhealthy
back-end connection closed before data
sent to client indicates that the
back-end unexpectedly closed its
connection to the load balancer before
the response was proxied to the client
this will be the focus in our video
back-end timeout indicates that the back
end did not respond within the service
timeout period configured for the load
balancer response send by backend means
that the 502 error response was sent by
the backend itself all right let's dive
into a quick demo and learn how to
troubleshoot and resolve a live 502
error
when you observe 502 errors with the
load balancer do the following
go to the logs explorer page in the
google cloud console choose cloud http
load balancer from the resources drop
down menu to view the logs highlight the
forwarding rule associated with your
specific load balancer and choose the
particular url map
narrow down the search to a specific
time range during which the issue was
observed in our example we will set it
as the last r filter the logs to check
502 errors in the last r
the logs show that there were several
occurrences of 502 errors open one of
the log entries to get more details
about the 502 error scroll down and
check out the value of the status
details field inside the json payload
this field suggests why the load
balancer returned the http status code
502. in our example the status details
field has the value back in connection
closed before data sent to client this
indicates that the backend unexpectedly
or abruptly close its connection to the
load balancer before the response was
proxied to the client typically the
back-end instance will close the tcp
connection abruptly if it has a lower
tcp keeper live timeout compared to the
load balances tcp keep alive timeout
which is by default 10 minutes to
confirm this let's check the tcp keeper
lifetimeout set on the backend instance
go to network services load balancing
and choose the load balancer in our
example it is test http lb this load
balancer is configured with back-end
service nginx backend with the back-end
vm installed with nginx web server let
us ssh into the vm and check the tcp
keeper live timeout configured on the
web server
the value for tcp keeper live timeout
can be viewed in the slash etc
nginx slash nginx.com file
there you go the value for the keeper
live timeout is configured to be 1
seconds which is much lower than the
keeper live timeout value configured on
the load balancer which is 10 minutes
this is the cost for back end to
prematurely close the tcp connection
with the load balancer and load balancer
eventually returning 502 errors to the
client it is recommended that the keeper
life timeout on the end should always be
configured with a higher value compared
to the keeper life timeout on the load
balancer to resolve this issue increase
the keeper life timeout value on the
backend vms we will set this value to
650 seconds
to learn more information about the
values in the status details field and
to troubleshoot and resolve other common
issues with google cloud external https
load balancers check out this
documentation thanks for watching
[Music]